[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to tonight's
episode of beginner breakdown my name is
Alex mullering and in honor of
Valentine's Day I have composed a poem
for us to start roses are red violets
are blue today is the day to learn
something new I've played many games
where I've won lost or Drew so I have
some tips that might just help you
there's no worse feeling in chess than
making a blunder one move on its own can
tear your position asunder
but listen to me and you might not go
under with these two simple tricks I'll
fill you with Wonder
so the two tricks in question are how
can we stop ourselves from blundering
and this is something that frustrates a
lot of new and old players alike in this
game it's something I have done a lot
it's something every chess player knows
the pain of
and the two tricks I have are very
simple one of them is kind of just a
practical piece of advice
and the other is an approach to how we
think about this game so I would like to
go through a few different games very
slowly and surely and really break it
down piece by piece because I think if
we start to take our games more slowly
and just follow a few really simple
steps it's going to help out now I've
talked about how to select our moves in
the past and how you think on your turn
versus your opponent's turn and some of
that's going to come into play here too
but the main thing that I think will
help you to avoid blunders and again
there's two but the first one is
whenever your opponent makes a move
really pay attention to that last move
and ask yourself what was the point
so let's talk through that by going
through this game as an example I played
this game against a friend of mine who's
not a beginner but doesn't really play
chess that often
and I have the black pieces
in the game he played the move Pawn to
E4
now with opening moves if we really try
and break down the exact point the
threat the ideas
um
with every single step it can get a
little tedious but we don't have to go
super overly complicated right so with
the openings you always want to think
about the opening principles the three
opening principles that we kind of use
are control the center of the board so
these four Center squares E4 D4 E5 and
D5 are very important the reason we want
to control the center is because really
it leads into one of our well let's
start with our second principle so
besides controlling the center we also
want to develop our pieces so things
like the knights the Bishops especially
we want to get them to places where they
can attack the center so again but why
do we want to control the center why do
we want to develop our pieces towards it
it's ultimately about the king you want
to keep your king safe and attack your
opponent's king and putting pieces on
one edge of the board
right if we keep all pieces on one side
if our opponent is able to Castle the
other way then our whole Army is going
to have to switch over and re-navigate
and so putting stuff in the center means
it's more likely to be able to disperse
to wherever the King goes whether it's
staying in the center or fighting on the
king side or on the queen side we're
always going to be prepared
okay so E4 what is it doing with those
principles one it's putting something in
the center the fact that this Pawn
occupies A Center Square doesn't really
matter because it's not defended by
anything but it is attacking D5 so we do
have some hold in the center of the
board
additionally probably a little more
important is we're opening up diagonals
for the bishop and the queen to emerge
so that's kind of what you want to do
whenever your opponent plays a move you
want to ask yourself what is the point
and because you don't know exactly what
my moves are or what I played we're
going to do the same with me
I played the move D6 in this game
so what is the point of this move and as
we go on this is going to be less about
solving puzzles there might be a few
examples where you're trying to find the
best move
but really think about what are the
reasons for any moves that might play
feel free to comment in the chat as
always
or just pause the video at any point to
think about these positions deeper
always totally fine
um but the reason I play this move is
it's kind of a hyper modern opening I'm
not immediately taking the center or
fighting for it with a pawn like a
classical system would do instead I'm
delaying that and I'm going to fight for
it a little bit later
um I am controlling one Center Square
here on E5
so I'm preventing my opponent from maybe
pushing this Pawn in that direction in
the future so that's one nice thing I'm
also opening up this diagonal for my
Bishop to develop one day so again it's
a little more solid not really assertive
as a move but these are some of the
reasons these are the points and when we
think about the point of a move or the
points if there are multiple reasons
someone would do something which usually
there are
it's going to help us avoid uh really
obvious blunders because we can see what
very easy threats are or we can see what
squares are being controlled and you'll
follow as we go so I played D6 my
opponent played Knight to F3
so let's think about this move
with the principles it develops a night
it develops one on the king side of the
board so it's getting ready to Castle
clearing some space it's controlling
some Center squares E5 and D4
seems very reasonable
I played Knight to F6
and very similar to white I'm developing
a king side Knight attacking the center
but there's something different about my
move so what is the main point of Knight
to F6 because everything I'm saying this
is all good but now we want to start
looking at really the critical ideas
so what's the main point of this move
and you don't have to get too
complicated with it it is pretty clear
that our Knight is attacking this Pawn
on e4
so in addition to just doing all the
normal developing we are making a threat
against this pawn and so if that's the
first thing you look at you should very
quickly be able to respond in this game
my opponent very quickly after I played
Knight of six played the move Bishop to
C4
because my opponent was kind of just on
autopilot not really thinking about what
I was doing
um and didn't actually pay attention to
the moves I was making just said I'm
going to push my Pawn forward develop my
pieces castle and then kind of pay
attention to what my opponent does this
is a very common mistake for beginners
to make and it's something you can
really easily avoid if you ask yourself
that really simple question of what is
the point this isn't going to solve all
your problems in chess but it's going to
help you avoid blunders
so what is the point of my move I'm
attacking this pawn and his move is not
like terrible it is uh making some
pressure against F7 so I want to think
this is the point he's developing his
piece preparing the castle and making a
threat but is that enough reason to
justify giving up a Central Pawn
probably not
when I play Knight takes C4 and here we
want to think about something else very
important
it doesn't so much matter in this
position but the idea will come up a lot
is the main point uh oh so come back to
this so if my opponent had played E5
it's a good question we could ask
ourselves the same thing what is the
point of this move well probably the
main point is to attack our Knight it
also attacked this pawn
and those seemed the main ideas
if it were me I probably am just gonna
take here
perhaps I can play Knight to D7 as well
but I think either of these moves are
reasonable maybe Knight to D7 is
actually a little bit better and I can
put a lot of pressure on this Pawn
potentially they will play E6 but I I
don't want to get too caught up in the
weeds of the opening really either way
whether I take or Retreat is probably
going to be okay you might be able to
make an argument for playing Knight to
G4
um but the important question is we want
to think about what is the point right
what is the reason they played this
might be a good or a bad reason but we
still want to think about that
so Bishop to C4 developing and I take
and whenever you make a capture or a
recapture you do want to think about
these questions as well the main point
is to get the material or take it back
but there are supplemental points right
so sometimes it's helpful to treat it
both as a capturing move but also think
about it as if they had just moved this
piece to the square without anything
else being involved so what if there was
no Pawn on e4 and I just play the move
Knight to E4 what is the point of that
move
um well I'm putting some pressure on F2
that could be important I'm putting a
knight in a Central Square controlling a
lot of important space so you know
centralizing your pieces again is always
going to be helpful
um
sometimes you should look at discovered
threats as well so it's not just the
fact that this piece moved but maybe now
something on a diagonal behind it or a
pawn can be pushed that couldn't be
before so these are some of the things
you want to be thinking about as we
continue
my opponent here doesn't see any
immediate threat because there really
isn't one I just recaptured a pawn
and place to move Queen to E2
so what is the point
or points right so what is the main
reason they played this move
and this is going to help us avoid
blundering
well there might be a few purposes
but I think the main one and again this
is still a little Elementary but if you
have questions feel free to comment them
and as we get deeper feel free to ask
and chat some ideas up but here the main
point is it is attacking my knight my
night is not defended so Queen E2
threatens to take it some supplemental
points perhaps defending this bishop
could be helpful perhaps opening up
space for maybe a queen side Castle
although that's unlikely more likely my
opponent will kingside Castle when the
time is right but keeping some of these
ideas in mind I think is helpful
additionally as we talked about I think
last week in our discussion of tactical
signals alignment is something very
important so I'm immediately noticing
the fact that this king and queen are
lined up maybe there's a potential for a
pin I'm also noticing that this queen is
lined up on the E file with my king and
so maybe some of my pieces will end up
pinned that I need to be paying
attention to
however beyond the attack on my knight I
see no other immediate threats and so I
have some options
probably the safest move would just be
to retreat back to F6 I think that's
very reasonable in the game I decided to
play D5
which I think is a fine move I have
wasted one turn right because I played
D6 earlier so I've kind of wasted a
Tempo by playing this Pawn again but I'm
sort of winning it back by making a fret
I'm kind of giving away the answer there
but what's the point of this move well
it's twofold I'm defending my knight and
I am attacking my opponent's Bishop so
anytime multi-purpose moves can be made
that's really helpful because it's going
to one make it harder for your opponent
to identify the point now in this case
it's pretty obvious I'm doing both of
these things
but it's also going to be harder to deal
with because now in addition to solving
the problem you made you have to solve
your own problem and I can come back and
continue to fight
um I'm also very happy if my opponent
decides to trade here so if my opponent
wanted to play like Bishop takes D5
that's well that would actually not be a
trade I will recapture with the queen
and the queen will defend the Knight so
that would just be losing a bishop for a
pawn
but if my opponent decides uh instead to
allow their Bishop to be captured in
order to take my knight
I'm also happy with that since I'm up
this clean Pawn
okay so D5 and my opponent plays a
really interesting move here Pawn to D3
let's ask ourselves what is the point
here
why did they play D3 what is the reason
or what reasons uh
is this move the one that was chosen
and again I think there's lots of
answers
I would argue
the main point
is to attack my knight
it also defends the bishop but if I
decide to take this bishop the move you
play should not be Pawn takes Bishop
because then you're getting my Pawn for
your piece instead of my knight
so D3 the main point is it's attacking
my knight
and again I have a decision here to make
but I don't really advise trading or
offering trades like this when you are
down in material
so I don't know that this was the best
of my by my opponent but we still
understand the idea
now I played a bit of an interesting
move that I think is okay but maybe a
little bit dubious
probably here the safest is once again
just a retreat I have a nice control in
the center my opponent has to deal with
this threat to the bishop but instead I
play this move a little bit greedy
Knight takes F2
uh yeah welcome back to the chat uh
Doctor Who's glad to have you here
um and yeah Knight takes F2 is the move
I played thinking okay well I'm gonna
get rid of this uh another Pawn for my
opponent and I'm also still gonna take
this bishop
if you take me so my point the main
point is I'm taking a pawn I'm
threatening uh this Rook
and I'm too near the king so you have to
do something so my opponent takes back
and we want to think about these
questions
so
taking with the queen
one recapturing the piece and probably
better to do that than to take with the
King because if you take with the King
you can't Castle
well you say that some people in the
chat are saying that white is now a
little afraid actually
um there are some problems here for me
so once again notice that now this queen
is lined up at my weak F7 Pawn in the
starting position the f-pawns are the
weakest on the whole board
and actually I'll pop back to the
starting position
but they're the weakest on the whole
board because they are only defended by
the king
so White's King is the only defender of
this pawn and vice versa for black
um
and so if you can launch some attacks
against that it gets a little scary now
the good news for me is in this position
I'm going to remove this bishop so I
will solve that problem the point here
is I'm recapturing the material but
thinking about our opponent's last move
not only are they going to continue to
allow themselves to Castle but when they
do
that rook and queen are going to line up
against my weak Pawn
this is a bit of a concern
my opponent plays D take C4 recapturing
the material here this makes sense what
else is this move doing
well it's opening up VD file so my queen
is able to maybe become more relevant
and at the same time a rook might be
able to become more relevant if it ever
is able to slide over to this Square
so that's something to think about it's
also controlling some new new squares
one Central one here on D5 and the
square on B5 not sure how important
that's going to be but we want to take
note of it
um and those seem like the main ideas
here
and I do think my opponent has a very
scary move that they can play so I'm
actually already in this position a
little nervous
um
so if you had black here what would you
play because I do think again
considering the idea of our opponent's
re recent move not the immediate last
move which was this recapture but the
idea of them putting this clean on F2
they can makes a pretty annoying threat
okay so Doctor is recommending Pawn to
F6 now why do you want to play that move
because I actually like that move a lot
it's a really weird move to play but I
think it's very strong
Bishop E6 also in consideration
and I think these moves both have the
same idea in mind even though they're
going at it from different ways Bishop
F5 interesting as well
Bishop F5 I didn't considered that move
but I like that as well but I think
you're starting to see the threat the
idea we have to worry about is if this
Knight moves
especially if it moves somewhere like E5
then this Knight and queen will both
attack F7 the knight's gonna cut off my
King's escape on D7 and this is a
Checkmate threat
um
so something like Bishop E6 looks very
good now in the game I really considered
playing Bishop E6
I decided not to because I was afraid
that white could then play Knight to G5
and cause me a lot of issues
I don't really have a good place to put
this bishop I need it to stay here to
defend my king if I let them take and
double my pawns my king is also pretty
weak and again castling is coming very
soon and my king is going to be pretty
exposed so that seems a bit of a concern
so I don't want to let them double my
Pawns
Bishop can take on C4 sure but it's not
going to be able to stay on this
diagonal
at some point I'm going to have to
either leave
or stay here and allow them to double my
pawns so I think white would be happy to
give up that pawn on C4 so I thought
about Bishop E6 and was definitely a bit
afraid
um
F6 I also think is really interesting
because it's just stopping the knight
from jumping in general now if any of
you watch Ben Feingold he's a good
friend here at the chess club
um he says to never play F6 right never
push this F Pawn and I think that's a
very good rule the thing that's true
about Chess probably one of the most
true things is any principle or any
Axiom we use to help us play better
always has an exception
perhaps even that one has an exception
who knows
um
and so in this case I think F6 is good
the reason I think it's okay here is
because we are weakening our light
squares but we've already removed
White's light squared Bishop so that's
helpful and so they don't really have a
way to invade this queen is not
currently ready to attack any of our
light squares
so this is maybe something in the long
term will have to be a little careful of
but yeah as Ted Briley said weakening
these life scores is probably okay and
keeping this Knight completely away
keeping our F7 Pawn totally safe looks
pretty fine
so I think F6 is good the move I went
for here was not Knight D7 which to then
go to F6 I think that's an interesting
idea as well
um
I played Knight 2 C6
hoping to get a little more control in
the center and certainly stopping Knight
to E5 my plan for Knight to G5
was probably then to play F6
if I really was forced to in this
position this is probably what I was
going to do I'm not worried about any of
this because my Bishop covers it for the
moment
my opponent did not decide to do that so
again thinking what is the point of
these moves well the point of this move
is really a defensive one the point is
yes I'm developing yes I'm controlling
the center but the main point is I'm
stopping Knight to E5 because I've
identified that as a really big threat
so that can also play into the purpose
of Moves right you and your opponent can
both make moves whose reasoning is
defensive
um so it's important to recognize that
as well
my opponent castles
what is the point of this move
I think it's probably clear one getting
the king more to safety but also lining
up this really dangerous Queen and Rook
against my F Pawn
um
yeah Knight D7 could have given my
opponent some Tempo a little bit of
clogging it's that's perhaps true
um
I'm not really sure a little unclear but
I was happier with Knight C6
but yeah so looking at this position
this is a little scary
B4 is your idea for white at some point
yeah I think before there could be a
reasonable idea right try and lure my
knight away and even if I don't move it
you can then threaten to play B5 and
recurve this threat I think that seems
reasonable but I'm also happy I think
castling is also very strong
ideas again of lining up these pieces
one day like we said earlier the D file
has been open so maybe this Rook would
like to challenge my queen it doesn't
really have anywhere good to go I just
have to block so some of these ideas
so yeah this is definitely a little bit
scary I feel okay as black here but not
I don't feel great I need to be cautious
okay so looking at these as the main
threats I found a move that I was
actually very happy with
um F6 again is something I thought about
uh Bishop E6 as well all of these ideas
were still in my head ultimately I
decided to play E5
okay what's the point
why did I play this move
I think there's a few reasons but can
anyone identify the main point here
so one thing is I'm opening up the queen
so I'm giving her a little more
versatility
um to cover some of these night squares
capitalizing control of the center so I
agree with that and also uh again I'm
making I'm disincentivizing Knight to E5
the problem here is something like
Knight to G5 is still or even
potentially E5 could be a possibility
um because even if I they sack it
there's still this threat against F7 now
E5 doesn't work because my knight will
take and defend which was part of my
idea with this move I need to get my
king safe I would love to Castle and get
my Rook involved or even Castle
queenside but having this bishop able to
come out is going to be really helpful
and defending against this idea so if
Knight takes this does not work because
when I recapture I defend this is not a
reasonable play for white
um
so this was my idea buy myself a little
more time get some space in the center
my opponent plays a very very solid
natural move Knight to C3 what is the
point here I think there's two one of
them that my opponent probably was
intending one of them that my opponent
did not recognize but I think would have
been very useful as well
to me the main purpose of this move is
to actually defend D1
and prepare to drop the Rook over
which would challenge my queen this
would be very annoying I think that's
probably the main reason
um but it also controls the center and
it's especially controlling this E4
Square in case I ever get any funny
ideas of pushing this Pawn probably not
going to do that super soon but it's a
possibility
um okay here a secondary reason we can
see for E5 which I don't think anyone
noticed is now I play Bishop E6
because we had talked about that move
before right we said maybe bishop E6 is
an interesting idea and it's one that I
considered but again I just don't like
the idea of Knight to G5 coming and
forcing me to maybe double these pawns
it just felt very uncomfortable
so I thought if I play E5 first
now when Bishop B6 comes I can defend it
with my queen if needed so I'm not going
to have to double my pawns if it is
attacked
it's also adding this extra layer of
Defense so this was kind of partially my
idea for E5 it felt a lot better to me
as well giving me some space
so Ted Bradley you're kind of getting
ahead you're jumping ahead
um in in the game uh my opponent saw
this move and thought the main purpose
might be defending this but it's also
attacking C4 which then would hit the
Rook so doesn't want to deal with that
and my opponent plays B3 which has a
dual purpose
what are the ideas with this move why
did my opponent play B3 the obvious one
is to defend this Pawn
but there's a more subtle reason
um Knight G5 still to answer your
question while people are thinking about
this move
um I think Knight G5 still is fine
um
I can probably just defend with
something like Queen to D7 or probably
better would be Queen to C8 to not deal
with the rook and
well no probably I actually have to play
Queen to E7 now that I look at it
because I need to keep this Pawn
defended enough and it will be attacked
three times
but Queen to E7 and then I could even if
I really had to follow up with Knight to
d8 and defend I wouldn't want to do that
but certainly a possibility
um
Knight to G5 I do think is probably
still annoying
but yes a few people are saying uh okay
so people are really wanting to see why
Knight G5 doesn't win
and let me be sure so I'll double check
this but I'm pretty sure I'm okay if I
just play
yeah even Queen D7 is okay
um
again this move Queen E7 is fine if
Queen D7 ah the real key is Rook D1 is
not an issue because apparently I can
play this really nice move so quick to
say it is still okay but I can play
Knight to D4 here
I can either move the queen because the
Rook has not it's left it's Square so
it's not attacking here anymore so I'm
okay losing a defender or I can jump in
with a a knight and there's not a good
way to attack so that's a good question
um in the game I had not really
considered this Knight to D4 idea
um but Queen C8 was something in my mind
but B3 a lot of people are saying the
other idea is we want to find a good
spot for this bishop
and fan ketoing it looks decent now I am
not 100 convinced by this move I think
it weakens these dark squares a little
bit too much for my liking
um but here I came up with a another
idea I think this move is a little too
slow and I wanted to punish white for
that because white has given up a pawn
and has set up a really strong attack I
don't think you really have time for
some of these slower developing moves
um probably is better to just get the
bishop somewhere Into The Fray
and here again is Ted Bradley sort of
highlighted a little bit in the chat I
played the move B6
I don't think this is the best move but
it led to a kind of funny funny win what
is the point of this move
because I kind of used some psychology
here against my opponent what is the
point
yeah it looks really random it looks
very strange I'm undefending this Knight
this Pawn seems to totally irrelevant to
the position but I'm actually
threatening to play Bishop to C5
pinning the queen and the King these two
are lined up this move is not a threat
because of Bishop E3
that Bishop can defend it but I was
thinking about my opponent and his last
move was Pawn to B3 meaning he wants to
Fan Kettle this bishop
so I'm thinking his purpose is to fan
cat of the bishop I'm going to play a
very sneaky move that looks very normal
and
if he doesn't notice if he plays his
normal plan which is unfortunately what
happened he did not consider what my
move was doing what was the purpose it
defended the square and so he allowed
this to happen if he recognizes this and
just plays some other move he can still
play Rook D1 here he can still play
Knight G5 here like these moves are all
fine and good as he he as long as he
really don't move this bishop because it
can still jump in the way then it's
going to happen and this is an easy win
right but I think it's very important to
understand why I won this game right
it's about these very simple and subtle
ideas
and not thinking about what the purpose
of these moves are right my opponent
played a very logical natural move and
lost the game immediately
and if we go back to the beginning we
can see this trend from the very start
right uh E4 D6 Knight to F3 just normal
development ideas but he's not asking
what is the purpose of my move I'm
making a threat he does not consider
that so I take it
and we continue
and the game goes on a little longer and
he makes some threats and I have to be
very careful of how I deal with them
because I'm recognizing these are
problems
um
and I'm even trying to solve problems
that he hasn't created right at no point
did he ever play Rook D1 or Knight G5
both of which I think would have been
challenging moves to deal with
so I was maybe even thinking about his
purposes more than he was thinking about
mine
and when I see him play a move like B3
wanting to play this move I realize that
if the bishop moves he will fall victim
to a pin the only problem is I can't do
it yet I have nothing defending that
square so I played B3 or should I B6 not
objectively the best move but I'm
thinking about why I'm playing my moves
why my opponent is playing his moves and
how I can use that to my advantage it's
in his case not thinking about that led
him to a very easy mistake that any of
us could have made and me thinking about
that let me find a very easy win in a
position that has some dangerous
elements even though I'm up
um so uh yeah King
H1 also fine yeah if here if after I
play this King H1 this is totally fine
um again maybe the downside for white is
it's too slow
um probably Bishop E3 is best accepting
that you've weakened these dark squares
a little bit but you need to get your
pieces centralized you're down upon
um what's crucial to you is you keep
your attack going get your pieces in the
game that's going to be your your
winning ticket
no worries for not making it too class
in person glad to have you in the chat
um
okay so this was the first example game
I want to show a very similar one but
this time we're going to switch
perspectives and I'm going to show you a
game from my student
who was playing uh I think he was
playing someone in a tournament
um
and this was the recording of that game
so uh not gonna name names because they
didn't ask his express permission but I
think it is a very instructive game my
student here has the black pieces
and here's how the game goes E4 E5 again
these moves are quick and opening and
obvious but we still want to be thinking
right opening up these diagonals for the
Bishops opening up for the queen
controlling Central squares right what
are the purposes of these moves Knight
to F3 what's the point
the main point is it attacks the pawn in
addition to its development
and helping the king castle Knight to C6
main point is it's defending this Pawn
in addition to everything else
uh yeah NN stands for no name or
Anonymous so this was I don't know the
name of the person my student was
playing
um Bishop to C4
what is the point of this move we kind
of talked about it a little bit in the
last game but this was uh yeah a
different
in this one I didn't play D6 or sorry
this was my student so the game played
differently the point here though is the
same it's this bishop is targeting this
week F7 Pawn often there will be tactics
here with the Knight with the queen so
things you want to watch out for already
and my opponent plays Bishop C5 kind of
just continuing the same ideas
we have castles
getting the king to safety that's a good
enough reason on its own to play that
move that seems like the main point and
pawn to D6 solidifying the position
defending the bishop and opening up uh
this diagonal for the light squared
Bishop seems reasonable
white plays Knight to C3
black plays Knight to F6
D3
opening up for the bishop
white plays Bishop to G4 all right this
is the first move we should stop and
really do some thinking what is the
point of Bishop to G4 do we think it's a
good move yes or no and why
so what is the reason why black has
played this move
and what do we think about it
couldn't he play D5
I'm not sure Donald which position
you're talking about that he could have
played D5
but that black could have perhaps is
what you're thinking of but I'm not too
sure
um
I don't know that there was ever a great
opportunity for it with this Pawn on e4
a lot of pieces controlling this Square
the earlier on it gets better but since
the first move is controlling here it's
usually not so good to play D5 and you
can play a Scandinavian defense but it's
going to get your queen a little bit too
far out
um
real quick we'll jump back so third move
here D5 would be a mistake if we play it
on move three
it's this square is only controlled One
Time by the queen but it's controlled
twice by our opponent's pieces so we
don't want to play D5 it does block the
diagonal temporarily but it's not
defendant enough so if you wanted to
play D5 you would have to play something
like Knight to F6 first to add an extra
layer of Defense
okay let's jump back because a lot of
people I think have suggested the idea
for Bishop G4 right what is the reason
for this
I think the main reason is it's pinning
the Knight to the queen so getting this
piece stuck now is that a good idea
it's reasonable
um the times you might not want to do
this are when you are kind of provoking
your opponent to push forward but we
don't really mind them doing that in
fact that's what happens in the game H3
we Retreat and white here did not play
the move Pawn to G4 which does push the
bishop away but also exposes the king a
little bit more right you generally want
to keep your pawns a little closer to
the king so white has a very annoying
pin to deal with
however
white does the same thing now white
plays Bishop to G5 with a very similar
point
and in this position
it's actually really interesting
my student here played the move kingside
castles
and missed something
so after Bishop to G5
white is making a threat so what is the
purpose of this move it's pinning the
Knight as we said but a pin on its own
usually isn't good enough right
sometimes if you can pin a piece that
can't move or be defended then you can
just win material but usually we have to
do something with a pin so for anyone
who has seen the lecture on pins one of
the earliest ones I did the pin is
mightier than the sword we talked about
three principles with a pin one of them
is pin pieces are petrified so they just
can't move second one is they don't
protect so squares they normally would
defend they're no longer defending and
the third one is you want to pressure
pinned pieces and the problem with
kingside castling
is it does not stop
White's big threat which a lot of people
have seen Knight to D5
now this piece is attacked twice it is
defended twice
but we're gonna have to lose either the
queen or we're going to have to break up
our Castle to keep it safe
because we cannot drop our Bishop back
we cannot challenge this piece it's a
really annoying position to be in
so in the game my student here saw this
move and thought okay I need to do
something about it and his solution was
to play Queen to D7 to get out of the
PIN
now this move is problematic
um
but there are some ways to kind of get
out of this probably the best here
is to play H6
and accept that we're going to get some
double Pawns
not ideal especially around the king
side but
you can also turn some of those
disadvantages into advantages right for
example something like H6 take take
while our Kings exposed we can also
maybe use this as the benefit of getting
an open G file to attack our opponent's
king
so that could be nice
unfortunately with Queen to D7 we have
lost one of our Defenders and actually
also put our queen and king Forks
distance away from a knight which a lot
of people have spotted so in the game
Bishop takes F6 was played and my
opponent or sorry my student realized
that if I take back I will get my pieces
forked so he correctly did not play Pawn
takes Bishop he accepted that he lost a
knight and decided to make the best of
it
Rook from F to E8
okay
what's the point
well maybe to get this Rook onto the E
file although I'm not sure how relevant
that will be
and we don't have to spend too much time
on this particular game but I do want to
get to a position because my student
here actually managed to come back and
win this game with some really nice
ideas but let's see how we get there
so white plays Queen to D2 what is the
point of this move
well I think it's also to get out of
this pin right the same threat is
happening before
the problem here is White's best is to
probably take this Knight and expose the
king but my student uh reasoned that
he's down material and even though he's
exposing the king he doesn't want to
make an even trade and so he did not
take that piece
instead he played Pawn to H6
looking to stop the queen from entering
G5 so that's maybe a second point to
this move is now Queen to G5 is a really
scary threat threatening Checkmate
threatening the bishop not an unsolvable
threat we can drop the bishop back
perhaps but still something that he was
worried about so he played Pawn to H6
uh White continues this attack with
Knight to H4
this whole time this bishop is hanging
and we sadly can't take it because this
threat of forking our king and queen
persists
but Knight H4 what is the point of this
move what is white thinking
any ideas
why might white have played this move
here
my chest rating I'm about 1500 USCF
better and worse on some tournament days
just depends but I'm about 1500.
um so yeah so I think the main reason
for this Knight H4 move is white would
like to really try to attack this King
side it's looking to occupy the very
nice Square F5 where it's going to hit
G7 it's going to hit H6 it's just going
to be kind of too monstrous and all of
these pieces are eventually going to be
too much for white to or sorry for black
to overcome
so I think Knight F5 is the plan
my student again makes a bit of a
misplay here Queen to E6 his idea is he
really desperately wants to get the
queen in the game he wants to attack his
opponent's pieces and uh it's a very
understandable struggle it's very hard
to play in this position
now he missed something his opponent
also missed it his opponent played what
looks like a very good move
his opponent played Knight takes C7
forking the Rooks and the Queen and this
is okay
however it undefends this bishop
so Queen takes F6
so let's jump back in time what would
have been yeah Cameron has found the
right move here the best move for white
would have been Knight to E7
because again the issue of alignment
this queen and Bishop have lined up
and if the Knight moves with a
discovered check the queen will be lost
you can either take here and lose it
this way you're still probably going to
get these two pieces for it but consider
more down a piece a piece for a queen is
not a very good look
um
you can also take with the rook and
maybe something like this but regardless
this is not going to be very good for us
um again thankfully his opponent didn't
see it saw some material to grab with
this Fork allowing Queen takes F6 and
Knight takes A8
and now
it's black to move what should we do
because even though it's been a very
hopeless position we got we lost some
material we ended up in a very cramped
structure things are starting to open up
a little bit
and we might be able to come up with
some ideas and not A4 but you have the
right idea dangerous right Queen takes
H4 you saw the move the knight's hanging
because he played it here earlier
and that's something that was nice to
find
keep an eye on undefended pieces
and now
we're down material but it's not so bad
white plays Knight back to C7 trying to
escape
Rook to E7 attacking the Knight and
keeping this Pawn defended
Knight back to D5
Rook to E6 looking to bring the Rook
into the game slowly so white has
managed to save the Knight but now
Black's pieces are kind of congregating
here towards White's King
white place to move Bishop to B5
attacking the Knight
and uh White here or sorry black here
plays Knight to D4 getting out of the
attack bringing his Knight more into the
center making some threats this is very
strong but I want to see if you can find
the reason why
because white played Bishop to D7
attacking The Rook
and it's black to move and find a very
strong move
this is a really hard one to find my
this my student found a good move but
not the best move
uh could white have played Knight to F4
I don't know when the Knight would have
been able to get to F4 earlier Knight to
F5 would have been better he still would
have lost a knight but it would have
been a less valuable one yes
in this position
my student played the move Rook to G6
getting the Rook out of danger pinning
this Pawn to the king and causing a lot
of problems and he would eventually go
on to win and we're going to look at how
but we'll I'll give you a fun puzzle
with your chest thinking caps see if you
can find the best continuation here for
black
yeah so a lot of people are starting to
put it together
again always feel free to pause if you
want to find it yourself the best move
here is Knight to F3 a forcing move but
we got to understand why so let's think
about this this is check it's forking
the king and the queen so you really
have to take if you don't take we're
gonna win the queen and black is better
so you have to take
and what happens after Pawn takes
uh yeah you're very close to the right
idea
let's see if we can find the precise
next move so Knight takes F3 Pawn takes
black to move
Queen to G3 very good so there's some
complications happening right now first
we get a fork that is a sacrifice but
also notice the point of this move right
we can apply our idea of understanding
the point to these tactics as well the
point is not just to Fork the king and
the Queen and force the pawn to take
it's also to discover
a pin so there are three tactics a fork
well a sacrifice as well a pin that is
discovered so it's a very beautiful
combination because this pin is
discovered this pinned Pawn does not
protect this square that it normally
would which allows Queen to G3 check
and Bishop takes F3 check mates
really really beautiful tactic to find
there
um however even not finding it White's
position has kind of withered away and
even though white has a material Edge
Black's pieces are all lined up at this
King and it's just too overwhelming in
the game white played the move Pawn to
G3
uh trying to just do something to attack
this queen but did not recognize this
threat of Knight to F3
you cannot go to the H file because we
will play uh
what will we do if King H1
I think we have a very concrete way to
end probably we can still just take this
queen and if you take ours it'll be some
Checkmate here you can bring the rook in
this looks very promising for us
um
but after something like King G2 simply
Knight takes D2 and this Pawn is still
pinned
uh so a really fun game for my student I
think very instructive as well to think
about what the point of these moves are
and how you can avoid some of these
blunders right if early on my student
had been thinking a little more
critically about this move Bishop to G5
what is the point it's pinning this
Knight okay well what's a pin do a pin
stops you from protecting the scores you
normally do White's going to look to
pressure this piece because it can't
move so something like Knight to D5 is a
big threat okay so once you identify
that how can you make a selection well
we think what can stop that threat do we
have anything that can stop Knight to D5
do we have anything that can break this
pin before Knight D5 becomes a problem
probably the easiest thing to do is just
to play H6 and if you retreat I can play
G5
and I have not committed to kingside
castling yet so you could always move
this queen up and queen side castle and
play a very reasonable game from that
position
so that seems like the best again
obviously if they would take we would
take back
but something to deal with that threat
that's probably the best maybe there are
some other Solutions but when you think
about what the point of your moves are
and the point of your opponent's moves
it becomes a lot easier to avoid some of
those blunders
um
okay I think we have time to look at one
more game I'm not going to look at this
all the way through
um
but let's look at the beginning because
my I was playing an opponent who is uh
much more a beginner and he played very
well until he just made one obvious
blunder so let's talk about this game I
had white here
and I played Pawn to E4
and I think someone chat was asking
about the Scandinavian earlier
uh Pawn to D5 was his response so we've
talked about E4 right the point of this
move is it's controlling D5 we've opened
up the bishop as well and the Queen
so what is the idea with this D5 move
what's the point here
uh this was an in person or no
I think this was a correspondence game I
played online with this friend so he
just kind of flipped open the game and
played some moves
but yeah so what is the point of D5 what
are the reasons you might play that move
what should I be thinking about as the
white player here in responding to this
move
uh and Ted Bradley with the right ideas
here directly challenging the center so
one of the benefits to this move is it's
immediately asking what are you going to
do about my attack because it's
attacking a pawn that's not defended
um
I think the downside to this it also
sorry I should say it opens up the queen
on the D file it opens up the bishop to
come out
I think the downside here
is after I take if you take back with
the Queen the normal Scandinavian move
then I can just play something like
Knight to C3 and attack the queen
and um
yeah so as Cameron here saying in the
chat sometimes they will say okay maybe
this Knight is misplaced but we do get
some nice Tempo and
I I think this is a very comfortable
position to play probably from both
sides objectively probably a little bit
better for white
my opponent decided to play a little
tricky
my opponent played Knight to F6 so not
taking back this Pawn immediately
actually looking to maybe punish me uh
by getting some quick development and
play some tricky lines
now you could try and hang on to this
pond with something like C4
I'm not really comfortable with that
because then we can open ourselves to
stuff like the Icelandic Gambit and some
really kind of interesting scary stuff
where I think black does get some
compensation there's also now ideas of
bringing the bishop out to G4 making
some annoying threats this way
it's kind of an interesting position I
the way I handle this is Cassandra's not
going to mess with it but the point is
clear at the very least black is looking
to recapture this Pawn without the
problem of getting their Queen involved
um
and now there's no tempo
however I decided to just play the move
d4
not really worrying about what black is
doing allowing them to retake with this
pawn and eventually I would like to play
Pawn to C4 and attack their Knight
so I play Knight to F3
controlling the center developing my
opponent plays Pawn to G6 looking to
activate their Bishop on this kind of
fianchetto diagonal
on G7 and now I decide to play C4 to
push the Knight away
um my opponent did not go for all this
bishop G4 nonsense in this game that
would be a whole another lecture if they
had
um here my opponent plays Knight to B6
so you have to retreat it somewhere I
think Knight to F6 and B6 are both very
reasonable moves he goes for B6 and what
is the point here well he's attacking my
Pawn on C4
and perhaps he doesn't want to be in the
way of this bishop so if he's on Knight
F if the Knight had gone to F6
than when the bishop jumps in uh there's
at least one more piece in the way he
might have just wanted a more direct
challenge to the center
um
it's also as we said attacking this Pawn
C4 but that's not an issue because I am
defending my Pawn so I just continue
with another normal move
Knight to C3
controlling the center against standard
opening principles
my opponent plays Bishop G7 and we can
see another point to this knight move
whichever way the Knight had gone we
also have to be aware again that the
queen is opened up on this Square
so the queen and Bishop now work
together to attack this Pawn
thankfully I already have my knight in
Queen not defending so it's still not an
immediate issue
um but
something to at least be aware of the
pressure is being added perhaps
something like Knight C6 one day or Pawn
C5 or something could eventually add
more pressure
in the game up to this point uh my
opponent and I have both played I think
very standard opening moves and I play
Pawn to C5
and maybe seems a little unusual kind of
pressing a little too far I think it's a
reasonable move this Knight doesn't have
a lot of good squares to go so I'm kind
of capitalizing on space and I can even
continue to push forward with these
pawns one day in a pretty comfortable
position
and I don't really think like yes this
Pawn could become backwards but I'm also
happy to try and break through with it
as well
so
in this position my opponent made an
unfortunate move which I think can be
mitigated by asking some of these
questions but not really the what's the
point because this is a little bit
different
um
my second piece of advice right I gave
the first one that's what we've been
looking at this whole time is whenever
you or your opponent make a move try and
identify what's the main point what's
the main reason that they are doing that
um and that will usually help you avoid
blunders
the second thing I like to do is
whenever I've decided the move I want to
play
so let's say in this position I'm
playing as black and I want to play some
move let's say I want to play a really
bad move like Knight to D5 maybe it's
not terrible so I want to play Knight to
D5
before I play it and this is true
whether I am playing online or uh
playing over the board
something that my old chess coach taught
me it's not something that I really do
literally anymore but his advice was to
sit on your hands so if I was playing
over the board I would say okay that's
the move I want to play and I would be
sitting on my hands so I had to take an
extra second to move my hand over to
grab the piece and play it the reason
for that is in that one extra second or
two before I make the move I think to
myself
am I missing anything obvious am I
hanging a piece
is a peace attack that's not defended
um
and in this case if you play something
like net D5 okay it's defended I can
take it with my knight you can take it
with the queen that's probably fine
um in the game my opponent played the
move Knight to C4
here's probably what happened because I
didn't really ask but this was again A
friend of mine
but he I think was just doing his job at
work and had the computer open and
pulled open this uh this chess game
didn't really look too long and hard it
saw his Knight was attacked saw he
needed to move it and saw oh C5 looks
like a normal Square
uh someone calls them sanity checks yeah
I like a sanity check so what he could
have done is he's sitting on his hands
is he looks to move the piece and say I
want to put it here
and then very quickly am I hanging
anything is something attacked that I
didn't pay attention to what was the
point of my opponent's last move
and here you can see oh wait C4 is a
square that is covered by my opponent's
piece I cannot tell you how many times
when I was playing in chesterman's in
high school that I would play a move
well usually here's what happened for me
is I would imagine all of this
variations I don't think okay I'm going
to go here and then here and then here
and then here and then here and then
here and I would see this really long
variation be like oh I don't really like
that and I would immediately just play
some other move that completely misses
the obvious threat my opponent made I
just do it without thinking so if that's
something that happens to you sit on
your hands think for a second make sure
you're not making any obvious misplays
that the piece you're moving is defended
it's going to a square other words not
attacked
um and it's that will save you in the
long run so these two tips this
Valentine's Day to help you with your
chest hopefully avoid mistakes and
blunders are to ask yourself what is the
point what is the reason for these moves
and then also uh don't just very quickly
place a move without considering just
take a second or two before you play it
to make sure you're not overlooking
anything
um
yeah that GM light goes exactly the kind
of the experience I've had of just
looking at all these deep ideas and then
playing something totally different that
you haven't looked at at all it's very
easy to do just always add in that extra
little buffer time for yourself to
really calculate and make sure you
haven't overlooked something very very
simple you will thank yourself for it
later
that is all the time we have tonight but
thank you so much for joining for this
episode of beginner breakdown I hope it
helps with your chest hope it helps you
not blunder as much as I have in my
chess career please stick around as our
next class will be uh taught by our
grand master in Residence uh should be
really fun so yes Josh Shang please
stick around for it should be awesome
until next time I'll see you later
[Music]
thank you